hey everybody I'm here with videogame
megastar PewDiePie this is your world
and now I'm here to ruin your career
thank you I appreciate that badger stop
stop it badger yeah do not make out with
a corpse
badger didn't warn me what are you doing
why am i attracted to these dead bodies
is that after being to say hey they have
glossy but yeah they're very toned
bottom hmm nice texture can I do
everything no I was trying to eat last
beer
make it count am i inside him you might
be inside him oh my god no censor it
you just beat here our own badger to
death I didn't mean to I mean you didn't
know oh my god castration that's a lie
I found that erotic it has an SNM
element to it when a woman tries to take
please don't explain it here making it
weird am i so look at the blood seeping
down through the wall from his penis
from his penis not go underneath man no
oh oh great Oh always good to get a
little penis blood on you I wonder if
there's any sex in this game I love it
when there's sex in the game because in
a way you feel like you're just playing
a video game but then there's porn I
just made everything very awkward right
now you realize I could ask these
cameramen to leave and then it's just
you and me who I by I'm just you and me
alright
[Music]
if you like this video for some reason
click here to watch more click on his
face
that's a ringing endorsement Rudy PI I
know how to say you like what just
happened you could have more I like that
yeah yeah good enough yeah go get it